hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
going to today we're going to work with
react native web so I got a new set up
if anybody saw the last livestream I did
for free code camp technically it was
just a disaster the audio is fine with
the video caps freezing constantly so
I'm gonna backtrack a little bit and go
over some of the steps that we did last
time that way you'll be able to see it
as well as hear it and I'm still getting
used to this new setup so I'm gonna do
try my best to keep track of what's
going on with the stream and in terms of
quality and then also the the chat so
let me know now if you can see this if
you can hear me if everything if
everything looks good then we'll go
ahead and get started I'm gonna say hi
to everybody in the chat Hey Umberto's
says hey hey how's it going the other
time the time is weird
so it is 8 a.m. in my time zone which is
Eastern Time so everybody's saying what
time it is
rabbit works javascript says they do
live streaming as well so that's awesome
yeah maybe I'll try to check that out if
I if I can't
all right cool we got people from all
over uh everybody's kind of shouting out
their location that's awesome
you got the last few Argentina India
Poland
awesome okay so Nepal really cool all
right so here's what we're gonna do I'm
going to start out by just like
installing or starting like create react
app project and then we're going to just
kind of switch it over to be to use
react native web if you don't know about
react native web I'll explain it briefly
here I think I go I explain it more in
the last stream so you could check that
out this is project seven so if you
check out the stream label project seven
day one you can get more info but
basically react native web is going to
allow us to use react native so all the
syntax is going to look like react
native but we will be able to run that
same code on the web in iOS and Android
we could run it as a desktop app on
Windows Linux or Mac by using electron
or something similar and then
potentially you know react native does
have the capability of running on other
things as well for now we're just going
to go with with those so the first thing
we're going to design for the primary
thing is as a web app I've decided to go
the web app first route because I'm
going to be able to display that while
streaming easier than anything else we
can run a simulator for like for mobile
apps but it takes a lot more out kind of
out of the computer in terms of like RAM
and CPU so I don't want to slow down the
stream for that so at some point we're
probably gonna want to test this
mobile like will definitely do that but
in terms of like our day to day
development we're gonna develop as if we
were developing like a normal web app
alright so we'll basically spend a lot
of time in chrome and that's cool it
gives us access to all the dev tools we
normally would it's the development
process is a lot easier than let's say
like using the simulator or using expo
and having like your device hooked up to
the computer so I mean XY certainly
makes that really easy but definitely
not as easy as just like a straight
straight web app okay so rabbit work
says visor is nice yeah so I have used
visor before so that's also nice but you
just like you can't beat the ease of of
the web app and in Chrome we can come
close but but for now we'll go with web
app so first things first let me let me
open this and I'm just gonna we're gonna
go to the react native web getup repo so
y'all can check it out see see what it
is you can read about it you know as
we're streaming your later on I'm
probably gonna mess up on typing a lot
because this is a new keyboard that I'm
not really used to yet all right so this
is react native web I'm gonna put the
link to this in the chat right now and I
see there's a lot of activity in the
chat I try to keep up with that but
about when we get to about the halfway
point in the stream I'll maybe stop
double check like what's going on the
chat and then at the very end of the
stream I'll check the chat again so if
you're asking questions or anything just
hang in there for a little bit and I
will I'll get to them soon
okay so that link is in the live chat
and we're gonna go through here we go
this is what I want the getting started
guide so we are going to yeah we're
gonna go through this for create react
app and this is what we did last time so
we're just gonna do it again and I'm not
exactly sure what I want to do with this
project yet my thought is this I years
ago I made a game to help my oldest son
learn math and I thought kind of like I
could redo that as an app with react
native web so maybe that's it I don't
really have any other good ideas for
what the project could be so let's let's
do that so let's go with create react
app and make sure I actually have create
react app on here this is a new computer
so the reason the stream is working now
and it wasn't working last time is
because I bought a new PC for streaming
and let's make sure
yeah this should work alright
and let's name it actually I'm gonna
name it like this battle math all
lowercase all one word that's gonna be a
bigger deal later on but there's some
rules about what projects can be named
that are different depending on the
platform so if we just stick with all
lowercase altogether
no hyphens that should cover every case
we should be fine so this is doing to
create react app you notice that was way
faster than then the last time we tried
to do this so much faster I tried to do
it on a 2015 MacBook Pro last time and
you know that's a good machine but it
just can't handle streaming and doing
stuff like this at the same time all
right so this should only take a few
more seconds and then we'll be able to
go back and add in react native web
support which let's see basically what
we're gonna need to do is add in react
native web because we already have the
other stuff
oops there we go
okay cool so let's CD into our battle
math directory I don't know I didn't put
this in I like that
I'll move this at some point but I
actually put this in the wrong directory
yeah shoot all right it's okay for now I
always like to put things in my projects
directory I didn't realize that wasn't
already in projects but we're in here
and now let's just open this we're gonna
open this all in code I'm gonna get rid
of this one and just to show we have we
have our basic file structure that you
that you normally get when you use
create react app here's our package JSON
right just all normal stuff so far and
then now at this point let's add in will
do yarn add react native web to bring in
that package let's show our terminal
yeah
okay if you want to know how I set up
any of this stuff like on Windows I did
a couple of tutorial videos on my
youtube channel the link to my youtube
channel I think is in the description of
this video so you can check that out I
show you how to set up node and get in
vs code on on Windows so that's this
should be like just the last like three
three videos or something on my on my
channel all right so we have react
native web here we can see it's now in
our package JSON and we're gonna need to
we're gonna need to add some stuff in
here
so you can see hopefully let me make
this just a little bigger and make sure
everybody can see it after we we do this
I'm going to go back to the chat so
we're not doing a custom web pack
configuration right because create react
app is already doing that
for us but
yet we're not gonna worry about jest or
flow for right now we're gonna have to
do babble men don't have to do babble
right now though we'll see we might be
able to hold off okay
yeah we might be able to hold off on it
but basically what we can do to test and
we'll see if I can get away with not
configuring anything else at this point
then that'll be great just to keep the
stream moving along what we're gonna do
to test this out is go into our our app
dot j s file so you see this is if
you're not familiar with react or react
native right like everything is a
JavaScript file and we use this syntax
that's called JSX that looks kind of
like HTML but it'sit's not kind of
behind the scenes it's actually all
JavaScript functions so we are going to
come in here and get rid of most
basically all of this stuff right we
don't want any of this stuff we're gonna
do our own thing here and so we're
getting rid of logo for right now I
guess we can keep the app dot CSS let me
let me go back here I think we can get a
just some boilerplate here
bref if he won't you like just what
we're doing no I just want some like
basic boilerplate sure
all right let's check out the code
sandbox template they have just so we
can grab it grab their boilerplate I
just want to be able to show you this
this actually running first so let me
check out the package.json for a second
okay
alright we're good the only thing we
didn't bring over react art which we may
need to at some point but I don't think
we'll need to for now so let's grab I'm
gonna just grab this real quick so I
don't have to type it all out and now
we'll go back here okay and I actually
don't want I don't think I need this
right now
we'll do textview and then we'll use
style sheet as well so what I'm gonna do
in here is put in a view to start with
alright and then inside the view I'm
gonna add text let me make this bigger I
wanna make sure everyone can see all
right hopefully that's easier to see so
we're gonna add in text and then inside
the text you know we'll just let's put
the title right we're gonna say this
battle math okay and if you didn't catch
it earlier like I built a game for my
son when he was learning basic math
we're gonna try to recreate that game
using react native web and hopefully
make it better as well and then maybe my
other kids can can use it to to learn
math ok so we have that and then we can
add our our style sheet in the easiest
way is just a copy and paste some of the
boilerplate for this so
let's grab this and then go back over
here I'm going to put on our Styles
stuff here let's get rid of basically a
bunch of this stuff I don't really need
any of that stuff but our main view
we're gonna say styles
I'm sorry style equals and we're gonna
say styles I'm gonna say roots since
this is basically our root component at
least technically it is I guess for our
purposes here so let's go root and we'll
just give it a let's see how I want to
do this
flex I'm trying to I want to Center the
text in the middle of the page so let's
go with justified content center and
aligned items this keyboard
sorry it's a new keyboard and we're
gonna go Center as well on the root and
let's just see if that works now before
we go any further with our styling now
by default react native uses flexbox so
that's why we're using normally you use
this with flexbox
i don't need to say that this that we're
using flexbox because that's that's the
default all right now let's get another
terminal going we can see back in our
package.json that if we want to run this
if you want to test this
we can use let's actually this
double-check that no I think about it
react scripts yep we can just use react
scripts okay so if we do yarn start
we'll get a nice little test version
here just like a normal will create
react app app we're gonna hit yarn start
see if everything works
whoa note server
what's file access I guess it's the
first time I try to do that
oops and it looks like I do need that
that other package that I neglected so
let's do everybody just saw all my
emails pretty much don't have anything
crazy in there so I'm not worried about
that
okay so let's yarn add what was that
called react art I think that's what it
was called let's double check yep react
art and get that in there and then it
should work
all right and let's restart that if
you're ever running a process in the
command line and you want to quit you
can just press ctrl C and that usually
does the trick so that's what I just did
right there just quit it and restart it
yeah check it out all right so I don't
know if you'd see that but it says
battle math really really small up here
okay now notice it's not vertically
centered so I'm guessing that's because
our container has no height right so
this is our route our route has no
height so we need to give that the
height of like full width if we really
want that to be centered but basically
the important thing here the cool thing
here is with very little work we've just
used react native syntax right these
views and text we've used that you can
see we're pulling it from react native
right which we we get this by bringing
in react native web okay we didn't
actually bring in react native on a
button by itself in our package JSON but
via react native web we have access to
all these react native primitives and
we've just used them here and then we
have them running in Chrome and if you
check it out I'm trying to make this as
big as I can
why is this not dark you can see this
computer is I've done almost nothing
with it yet because doesn't have my
normal settings but you can see like
I'll click on this this div here that
says battle math and the text it's it's
a div right
so those react native primitives have
been converted into Dom primitives right
so we have divs instead of view and text
it's now been transformed into divs and
then those styles that through the
react native stylesheet those styles
have now been added to these through
like all these classes right but let's
let's check on our route component here
and see where's our there we go
actually this is gonna be blocked by my
my picture here see if I won't be able
to see it
for just four
oops
all right so we have our okay yeah you
can see that justify contents enter a
line item center so you can see those
are actually on that that div alright
I'm gonna go back to the chat right now
and I'm gonna try to answer as much as I
can from the chat in the next few
minutes before we go back and maybe do a
little bit more with this project maybe
we'll actually push this to github too
before we end so that the the code is
available for you to check out I'm gonna
have to scroll up quite a bit there's a
lot in the chat let's just I'm gonna try
to get to as much as I can and let me
give myself a time limit here of about
five minutes okay we had a couple of
people asked if this was for beginners I
would say yes it definitely can be for
beginners I'll do my best to explain
things and certainly ask as many
questions as you want it there probably
be some things that are gonna be hard to
understand if you're a beginner but you
know just check it out and see if it's
too much that you don't understand
you know that's that's fine ask a lot of
questions I want to be open to beginners
but I also you know I want to build out
a project so some of the stuff is going
to be advanced let's see someone asked
if I read comments I do read comments
let's see
a lot of people were just saying hey so
I'm gonna say hi hi to everybody
Oh eff Therese furrow says saying hi
from South Africa hey how's it going
Oh Alex from Argentina
Minnesota hey so rabbit we're here in
Minnesota I'm gonna be speaking at NDC
Minnesota this year so if you end up
going to that conference or around there
let me know Benjamin from Kenya says hi
Newton from Nairobi awesome got Mario
from Houston Kamal from Uganda a mid
from Singapore yet seen from Turkey Wow
we got people from all over say it's 9
p.m. in China Liberia Bangladesh wow
that's really cool uh-huh it's just been
cool goshu guide says I want to ask you
can you read from files on JavaScript as
fast as C++ to be totally honest with
you I'm I don't have the answer to that
so yeah I just don't know if I had to
guess I would say C++ would be faster
but I really don't know and by faster
when we're talking about the different
languages it's usually like a few
milliseconds of difference fractions of
milliseconds right so in terms of
performance like only in very few
situations will that ever really be a
big deal for performance but that's a
good question does anybody actually know
any like real numbers on that in terms
of you know is JavaScript or C++ more
performant
yeah East Africa India Brazil
Philippines
Korea Japan
Ratto says could you make an API calling
app just for getting tweets or movies
yeah I mean that's certainly possible
are you asking me if it's possible are
you asking me if I could build it like
right now in the stream we definitely
could do something like that on the
stream probably not for this project but
for a future project Rob Mooney says
nice video thank you I appreciate that
the fellow from Amsterdam hey how's it
going
okay so rabbit work says talk about what
you're using NP X versus NPM okay I'm
gonna be 100% honest with you I don't
know that much about NP X okay the only
time I ever use NP X is when I'm
installing create react app okay so at
some point the official Doc's for create
react app started recommending using NP
x to install new apps with create react
app so it wasn't always like that like
that you can even see there's a link to
the instructions for older versions but
this seems to be the quickest and
recommended way to do it so that's why I
do it that way so I've never really
taken the time to look into it
you see there are alternatives right we
can do NPM in it
oops
we need yarn so there's definitely
multiple ways of doing this but MPX is
kind of a newer thing if anybody else
has any experience with that like more
experienced technically with that then
please let me know
Hector's just hello from Colombia hey
how's it going
limitless says what is MPX why not use
NPM okay so I mean basically the same
same thing the only reason I'm using NP
X instead of NPM is because that's the
recommended way to use create react app
rabbit works as MPX gives you the
ability to run package scripts and stuff
without having to install them as in
create react app alright that's a great
answer so like if you notice in the
beginning of the stream we never
actually installed create react app we
just we just ran this right and this was
a new setup on a new machine that I've
never really built anything on yet so I
I never installed it even before the
stream so yeah so I would say that alone
makes using npx worth it like taking
away that step of having to install
something else and thanks rabbit works
mr. Smith asks a question I'm not I'm
not exactly sure what your question
means there may be maybe it's a
translation thing like I yeah so mr.
Smith if you get it really ask your
question again maybe like explain it now
I'll answer it otherwise I'm not exactly
sure what you're trying to ask
all right Michael Creole says if you're
using npx you are sure to get the latest
version so that's that's awesome
radda says not scripted yeah this is not
not scripted at all AB AB he says how
long have you been practicing let me
think
like six years so I've been a developer
for like six years I think looks like
there's a conversation going on in
another language so I don't know if
you're just talking to each other or
whatever if we have time I can go back
and use Google Translate to see what's
going on but I want to get at least a
little bit more done with this with this
app so I'm gonna skip over it for now
I'm almost at the bottom of the chat and
then we'll go back and do a little bit
more code limitless ask about what it
what are the bundlers rabbit works as
web pack yeah so web pack would be
you're almost always when you're using
react you will also use webpack as your
bundler I've seen people use other stuff
with react but I've never used anything
other than web pack
okay rabbit Works is recommending using
react snippets to be able to generate
component boilerplate right away that's
that's a really that's good advice and
then react snippets wood is a like a
package extension for Visual Studio code
they probably have the same stuff for
other editors as well not sure how to
pronounce the name but the question is
what's the difference between create
react app and react native web okay so
create react app is just a tool that
lets you build out like the the basics
the bare bones for a react app really
quickly right so we just ran create
react app and then we got we had all
these files and stuff and folders so it
automatically created a lot of the stuff
for us that would have taken a while to
do on our own but it you need you need
it for every project it's almost always
the same for every project so that just
handles before us react native web it
makes it just allows you to use react
native syntax to build web apps so that
that would be the the difference
hopefully that answer your question let
me know if it didn't
Edward asked about what was react native
web you code and browser and then bill
for mobile yeah you you definitely can
do it that way but basically react like
I said rack native web just lets you
take the react native primitives and
turn them into Dom primitives so that it
can run on the web limitless asks why
did I use root to be honest with you I
kind of liked the idea of using whatever
the outermost container is of a
component and just saying root here I
don't remember where I first saw that
but I saw somebody else doing that and
so I like okay that's that's not a bad
idea it saves me from having to come up
with names for stuff and then I I know
like whatever's in this root those this
applies to the outermost container in
every component this is just the
outermost container for me so that's
that's what I use this for
let's see are there any examples of
react native website
I believe Twitter light is is used they
use react native web for Twitter light
and they use react native web for one of
the major league soccer websites so just
off top my head that's that's it so I'm
gonna go back to the code right now I
know I didn't get through all the
comments but I'll get back to the
comments in about 10-15 minutes
something like that alright cool so
let's get back in here and do just a
little bit more okay so here's the basic
idea of what this this app is gonna do
in terms of just like very very basic
what we're gonna do is the app is going
to have a text input and a button to
submit it needs that on like every
screen it's gonna generate a math
problem randomly alright and then when
you input the value and the text input
it's it will check to make sure that
that's the correct answer right and
that's how the game will progress
what'll happen is on the screen will
appear a certain amount of like enemies
if you get it right then one of the
enemies disappears if you get depression
wrong a new enemy appears so you can you
can get as many questions wrong as you
want without the game like saying game
over but it's just gonna take even
longer for you to get past it so
basically to get past a level you will
have had to like master that type of
math problem right we're just going to
start out with addition it's gonna be
very basic it's gonna be geared towards
young children
so we're not gonna do anything like
crazy in terms of graphics definitely
nothing super violent or anything like
that we want to keep it like appropriate
for young young children and so for now
I'm not gonna worry about graphics
everything is just going to be a bit of
text but we can build this out so react
native comes with a text input already
built in so we're bit we're gonna build
stuff out at first just an app j/s and
as it gets bigger will break stuff off
into separate components okay
so let's put this text input here and
let's go to the react native
documentation react native text input
Rack native Doc's are great you can see
all the info you need so we'll just take
this let's just copy and paste this this
basic example that they have so that we
can kind of get started as quickly as
possible so stir this in here and you
know what let's grab their their state
as well and I'm not going to let's let's
create our own state right because I
don't we don't need to use the
constructor right
we'll grab
when what do they call it text okay so
they call their state text
texts and at first let's just leave this
blank for now so what's happening here
is we have our text input right and
they've they've given it some style
we'll just keep that for now and then on
change text so this is a little bit
different than normal react right we
have this on change text and that's
every time the user types in that that
input this is going to be called we've
got a little arrow function here so
we're passing in the actual text the
value of that text input right and then
we're running this which is we're just
setting the state of text to text right
since the value we're passing in and the
key have the same name we can just do it
like this and then the value of the
input is actually the the state right so
it's kind of a circular you type in
there it changes a state and then a
change in state causes a rerender which
then changes the value that's what's
called a controlled input controlled
component there are other ways to do
this but this is the like standard way
to to handle an input in react all right
so let's save that and just just verify
that it works
that one okay cool so let's type
something a it works and we can go in
here to react and let's check our
States I sue our state for this
component there we go so our state for
our app component here is will change as
we type see all right cool
so that is working so let's go to back
here to our react occupation and let's
go to button and we're gonna add a
button so react native comes with this
button like pre-built if you use button
it will automatically style it
differently depending on the platform
right so according to the docs like
we're just targeting either Android or
iOS right and this will give it an
Android style and this will give it an
iOS style right we're gonna stick with
that for now we may want to put our own
styles on the button if that's the case
we'll stop using button and instead
we'll use touchable opacity which is the
primitive that button is built on right
and that lets us do a lot more in terms
of styling right but for now just to get
this the functionality you know going
quickly we're just gonna do this so i'm
gonna copy their example and put it in
here for now this button and we got to
make sure we're cool actually pulling
button in button and for now the we're
not on press we're not gonna do anything
because we don't we don't have anything
set up so we're just gonna console.log
oops
and this states text
okay and let's change this from learn
more to submit yeah oops now let's check
our app hey we got a big purple submit
button let's type something and then hit
that and that's we're all impressive
smart is required and button so he's
under fine alright so we've got an error
let's check that out
okay so maybe let me just put that in
arrow function see if that does anything
there we go okay so I should have put it
in an arrow function but basically we
can see we type we hit submit and we can
get the value in in the console right so
if you're not like familiar with react
at all and you've done some web
development before you know this is kind
of really different than you would
normally handle text inputs like it is a
little bit different instead of grabbing
values directly from the text input
we're grabbing everything from State
okay it may seem a little weird on this
scale but after you get used to it and
you start having more complex like use
cases you you'll see like actually
saving the value of everything in state
ends up being a lot more easy to deal
with than needing to grab values from
the Dom from multiple inputs so it's it
is a lot nicer it may not seem like it
with just one text input but you start
to get more and more on a page this this
does end up being a much easier way of
handling form inputs okay let me check
the time all right we're running I only
want the stream to last for about an
hour so we're getting down to about like
10 minutes left let me check the chat
just to see how much is in there and
then yeah there's a lot of chat how
about let's let's go ahead and create a
git repository for this and push this to
github and then I'll go back to the the
questions so let's do git status so this
is already like just started out as a
git repository when we use create react
app it does that so we've changed our
package JSON remember when we added some
packages we've changed our app J s and
then the yarn lock file comes with us
using yarn so that will change
automatically every time we update our
packages
so I'm gonna do a git commit with the EM
flag or I'm sorry with with the AM flags
we're gonna add an atom in commit and
add a message all in one line and let's
just say I'm just gonna say in it for
now because this will be our first
commit and yeah that's fine
okay so locally we have this repository
but we don't actually have it anywhere
on github so let's go to github if you
don't already have a github account I
highly recommend getting a github
account if if you'd like to become a
developer of any sort
you know just sign up as long as you
have it that's good and then you know as
we go through this and you see the
process of committing things to github
you you'll kind of get a better
understanding of what you would use it
for so I'm gonna create a new repository
right now I'm gonna name it battle math
okay I'm gonna skip the description for
now I'm gonna keep it public I don't
want to initialize it with a readme a
getting Noir or a license okay we can
add those in later now I'm going to use
the ssh version because i've already set
up my ssh keys if you want to know how
to do that check out the video about
setting up get on on my personal YouTube
channel links in the description but
since I'm doing that I can skip down
here we're pushing an existing
repository for the command line so I'm
gonna copy that I'm going to take it one
step at a time here I'm going to paste
that okay so this is we're adding our
remote right which is going to be the
the ssh path to that repository and
github and then we're gonna push to that
remote so we're pushing our master
branch right to the remote
great now if we go back here to github
and we check our repository you can see
hey here it is here's here's all our our
files right if we go to the source and
our app j/s you can see hey look there's
our our title battle math and here's our
text input and our button right so now
this is on github and I will give you
the URL in the chat right now and then
from now on I will if I remember I'll
put this URL in the description to the
video so everyone you can you can check
it out you could submit a pull request
if you want you'll you'll always be able
to see what's going on in this project
from there so I'm gonna scroll up right
now and try to get through as many
questions as I can in the next like
seven minutes or so and then I got an in
this stream and do my my real job as a
software engineer I'm trying to I forgot
to take note of where I left off at so
it might take me a second to figure out
where I left off
I think I found it
always the legend said mission failed
we'll get them next time I do not know
what that was referring to so I'm not
sure what's going on limit let's just
keep going perfect explain all right
thanks
limitless asked if I can talk more about
flexbox for a bit okay flexbox is a
newer thing in CSS that allows you to
position elements on on the page of of a
website or a web app so traditionally
this has been done in different ways
at one point tables were used people
also used floats to create layouts and
CSS flexbox is the default and react
native and then there's a newer way that
CSS grid although you can combine CSS
and great in Flex box
so basically flex box is a technique to
position elements on a page and it's
it's just CSS so if you check out flex
box there are a lot of cool tutorials
online like gamified tutorials flex box
froggy is one that comes to mind that's
out of a nice gamified flex box tutorial
so you can go through that just to learn
a little bit more the only thing I will
say in react native for for mobile the
the axis is flipped so if you know if
you don't know anything about flex box
this is gonna make sense but if you know
a little bit about it just know the the
axis is flipped so everything is usually
like the opposite of what you think it
would be so by default on web I believe
the Flex Direction is Rho the default
flex direction on mobile if with react
native is column so I think that's why
it's either that or the other way around
but basically the flex direction is the
is it what you'd be used to if you learn
flexbox
for web it's a little bit tricky to
learn at first but once you learn it it
it's really nice for positioning for con
asks if someone can explain the
difference between react and react
native we got it some some answers there
as well so Mario says react native lets
you build apps that can run on Android
iOS and yeah that's it so like react is
a JavaScript library or framework
depending on who you're talking to that
allows you to build web apps react
native allows you to build mobile apps
it but it's expanded into more so you
can build for more than just mobile with
react native but basically like at its
core what it was designed to do at first
was to build Android and iOS apps using
using react all these the legend says
when I just write math problems on paper
for the kid well that's how we started
actually like I created this game on a
whiteboard with markers playing and then
at some point I realized like hey like I
could make this a game like a computer
game right so I just kind of did it as a
side project so I I did it as a side
project just to help me learn a long
time ago but I found the project and ran
it like a couple days ago and it just it
just occurred to me like hey we could we
could just redo this Michael creo says
no Pomodoro
yeah I didn't I just forgot to bring up
the Pomodoro clock so we use it in
future streams sebek's is what course
should I take in college should be a web
developer I would say don't worry about
it in college take whatever you want
there are plenty of online courses a lot
of them are free to learn how to be a
web developer so go with that basically
plan on learning web development on your
own outside of what's offered in your
college Fatima's is a low from Libya hey
how's it going we have hello from Ghana
if hello from Egypt Nigeria India
Ukraine Nepal awesome
Ivory Coast's New Delhi Australia
Saudi Saudi Arabia ghost you guys says
the JavaScript does JavaScript use the
internet to read files or CPU I'm I'm
not 100% sure what you're asking there
so like when you're you're running
JavaScript in your browser right like
that's using your your CPU your RAM you
know everything like that so like the
JavaScript files will come to you over
the internet but what runs in your
browser will use your CPU now like there
could be some of that work happening
server-side so not on your CPU and then
the results of that would be sent back
to you all right so in a situation let's
say where there's a lot of calculation
or work that needs to be done maybe it
would make sense to do that server-side
and just send back some sort of visual
indication back all right but mostly
like running JavaScript in the browser
or that that is actually running on your
machine all right
rat OSA from Bosnia hey how's it going
oh hello from Kenya from Russia what's
your opinion about razor pages web app
with dotnet core actually so I just
recently worked with a web app like that
if your team is like heavy into dotnet
and doesn't really know anything else I
think that's definitely a way to go if
you want like a client-side web app like
a true progressive web app experience
you probably can't get that with Razer
pages so youyou are somewhat limited in
that but if you just wanted like an MVC
you type of web app Razer pages is a
legitimate way I wouldn't go out of my
way to learn it but if you already know
dotnet that's probably a the quickest
way to get a web app up and running
Monica says you are too good thank you
Rasheed says you explained very well
thanks I appreciate it
Davis if these shows are recorded yeah
they're recorded it'll be available on
the free Co camp YouTube channel shortly
after the stream ends sub eek asked the
question earlier about what course to
take in college to get a job so I had
recommended
you gotta learn on your own so beak says
I know but I want a degree to get a job
well then I do computer science then
like if you know you want a job in web
development computer science is probably
going to look the most impressive for
for that right like I mean my degrees in
business but realistically like if I had
a degree in computer science it would
probably help me more in my career as a
software engineer
all right I'm gonna skip through and
find just some questions
wait war arrow says why do you use
windows instead of Linux or Mac I use
Mac at work for the most part I use
Linux on servers but I needed a machine
that could handle streaming and it was a
lot cheaper to go with a PC than a Mac
so that's why I ended up doing a PC John
Henson says Jesse why no react hooks I
react hooks are not yet available for
react native but the react native 0.5
9.0 release is going to come out soon
and when that happens react Oaks will be
available so we would definitely update
and switch to react hooks when that
happens
all right I'm gonna have to end soon
because I'm gonna have I have a stand up
for for work coming soon but let me try
to get through these last few questions
rado asks about doing a live session
together where routers can create a PHP
API and I can implement interact app
that actually sounds really cool yeah we
could talk about that rathaus if you
don't already follow me on twitter
follow me on twitter I think the link to
my Twitter account is in the description
if it's not then just click the link to
my youtube channel and I have links to
my Twitter there so like add me on
Twitter and send me a DM about it and
maybe we could try to work that out
rabbit work says have to add work but I
hope people can check out my live coding
session this evening 5 p.m. CST alright
so check that out I'll see if hopefully
if I can if I don't have a meeting or
something then I can I can check it out
as well and I'm gonna show
let's see
all right so Tiago says does this mean
we can create native apps and websites
with the same almost base like ionic
framework yeah yeah basically
let's see
Pawel says do you recommend those
beginner developer about react I'm not
so I I think you're asking do I
recommend react for beginning developers
probably you don't want your very first
thing to be jump in the react first
learn HTML CSS and some basic JavaScript
before you go on to react but like if
you know HTML CSS in basic JavaScript
then for sure like I think react is good
it's easy to learn enough to make some
basic web apps in you know if you want
to get really advanced that does take
some time but yeah I think it's good for
let's say the beginner who's just trying
to get into their first framework after
learning the basics Acosta's what are
your opinions on mob x4 state management
I've never used my backs I've heard good
things about it so you know I think it's
definitely a good option although with
the react context API I think it's less
necessary to bring in a third party
state management library Pavel says
what's the difference between nodejs
Express Jas versus react to create a web
app okay so react is just going to be
your front end of your app like your
client side stuff although it can run
server-side but if you want to do
anything server side you need nodejs so
nodejs
is JavaScript running on a server now
Express is like a library that runs with
nodejs
that makes it easier to do server things
with nodejs so you would use nodejs on
your server with express to make things
easier and then on your client side
you're going to use react you could
potentially also render react
server-side as well
right for let's say for like search
engine optimization purposes right but
they it wouldn't be one versus the other
it would be you'd use them together
depending on your use case you might
want to use them all together or just
some of them right if you're building
just an API
you just need node and then probably
Express to help with that if you just
want client side you need only react but
if you want like both together a client
and server-side app if you're handling
like form data and things like that then
you're gonna want to use them all
together and on previous live streams we
go back and watch previous live streams
we've done just that and used react node
and express all together Michael says
you need G fuel I'm guessing you said
that right when I had that big yawn game
Explorer says do you use solo learn I
don't think I ever used solo learn I've
heard about it but I don't think I've
ever used it myself we have a lo from
Georgia hey how's it going
Anton says what's your opinion on web
assembly I think web assembly is awesome
and it's going to be very useful I have
not used it yet
if you don't know web assembly is
basically a way to use like other you
can use other programming languages on
on the web very normally like JavaScript
is your only web programming language
but it's a way to use without getting
too into it like you could potentially
use like let's say I don't know like
c-sharp on the web and things like that
right so really cool it's gonna present
a lot of opportunities for other types
of developers to get involved in the web
and it's gonna be a good opportunity for
web sites and web apps to be able to do
more so I think it's cool
make me proud keeps asking react native
for web yeah yeah so it's react native
that runs on the web
as a webapp
Ramos says what language is good for
web-based project
javascript javascript is where it's at
for the web
[Music]
cyberpunk says is this thing live and
recorded it's live right now and then
the recording will be available
afterwards
let's see
I think I've gotten all the questions
okay cool so yeah I definitely have to
go now I gotta get to work at my my day
job as a software engineer for Dick's
Sporting Goods I'm actually working with
react native web there so I'm gonna quit
the react native web stuff here and go
right back to my other project and use
it again thank you all so much for
watching I hope that I can start to do
these live streams on a more regular
basis now that I have my new computer
set up so we have reliable a reliable
way to stream I'm hoping that I can
maybe on like Wednesdays and Fridays in
in the morning in my time so right
around the same time we did today do
some live streams if I have time maybe
even on the weekends do some live
streams but if I can get at least once a
week and be consistent with that I'll be
happy for now love to be able to do it
more but you know there's just with the
new job and things going on it's just
been tough to find time so anyway I
really appreciate hanging out with you
all and I'm looking forward to the next
stream hey feel free to message me you
know you can follow me on Twitter or
Instagram I'm pretty active on those you
can message me with any questions or
anything you know check out the github
repo put issues up there pull requests
whatever you want check out my youtube
channel I go more in-depth into a lot of
things that I've used today and I talk
more about it so yeah until next time
have a great day have a great weekend
and I'll see it
you